Consciousness is creating a reality if
you put a picture of fear into your
reality then your biology Behavior will
manifest things to be afraid of because
this is a short statement but to me it's
the most powerful one simple and short
and it goes like this the function of
the mind is to create coherence between
your beliefs and your reality if I have
a negative belief the function of my
mind is to manifest Behavior to
experience those negative realities if I
have positive beliefs then the function
of my mind is to manifest a positive
experience but we got programmed with so
many negative beliefs and that takes
away our power because we're not
focusing on the beautiful things we're
focusing on the fear what are you afraid
of need motivation watch your top ten
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I struggle
to stay afloat I quit my business
partner and the thing that kept me going
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's learn from one of the
best Bruce Lipton and my take on his top
ten was a success
enjoy
rule number two is change your beliefs
there are three ways to change belief
okay
self-hypnosis earphones on at night
repetition create a new habit
and third one energy psychology which
allows you to rewrite an existing
program in minutes uh and we need to do
this why
because if you haven't noticed and you
haven't looked out the window the
world's falling apart I go and why is it
falling apart and the answer is because
we're facing what is called the sixth
mass extinction of Life the web of life
is collapsing I go then why is the web
of Life collapsing answers human
behavior
I go oh
you don't want the weather collapse
we have to change the behavior
and this is what the world is
experiencing at this time the chaos all
over the world is bringing to light the
fact that these behaviors were
fighting and violently with are
behaviors that have taken us out of
heaven
and put our Consciousness into a world
that we're experiencing which is falling
apart
you want to make a world of heaven then
you change the program and then you
could have Heaven it's your pool use
system that that creates this you fell
in love because you stopped playing your
program and you created heaven
I said well guess what heaven was always
there except the damn program got in the
way so you want heaven on Earth
don't play the program stay mindful or
be rewrite the existing program and put
heaven on Earth programs in there and
then 95 of the day you'll be playing
that rule number three is activate the
power of manifestation the body provides
us with Sensations
pain love joy happiness anger whatever
it comes from this mechanism it's a
mechanism the the eyes take in light but
they don't they don't see light back
here in the brain they say energy
vibrations
sound comes in my ears I don't hear the
sound I hear the vibrations taste that's
a vibration it's a chemical vibration it
almost says oh my God this is a
transducer it takes life experiences in
a body that gives us vision and smell
and taste and touch and pain and love
and joy and I say and this is sent back
to our source so we came here to have
life experiences and I go at that moment
of Awakening I said oh crap here's a
major difference between men and women
men are not allowed to have these
sensory experiences and I'll give you a
reason but women are so women are
sensitive they and that's a way of life
for them they're sensitive and then they
go about but men are so insensitive I go
that was a program
we were programmed to be insensitive for
a very simple reason you cannot be a
soldier if you're sensitive
you can't kill somebody if you're
sensitive so men have been knowingly
programmed to lose sensitivity so they
can be used to do those jobs like
killing somebody else
I go oh my God then I miss the reason
for being on this planet I missed the
feeling of what is love all about you
know what are these senses of joy and
happiness I'm not allowed to experience
them as a guy because uh that interferes
with a soldier job I go I'm wasting my
life and that was a wake-up call I said
well damn it go out and taste it and
touch it and feel and smell it and do
whatever you want if it's really good do
it again and if it didn't work out so
good then don't do that one again you
came here to have these experiences why
do you want to waste your life having
all the negative fear anxiety all those
problems it was a choice
it was consciousness
but we didn't know that because we were
programmed to be victim
and a victim has no power
and as long as you believe you're a
victim then you manifest victim
and this is why I'm so uh honored to be
with you Jeff because you're
experiencing this you know this stuff
you're trying to get this message out to
the other people why to wake us all up
because we came here to manifest heaven
on Earth like Falling in Love
and I go then what about all this war
and pestilence and plague and and all
these things I go oh that's a
manifestation
and we're manifesting it
you can live in this world without even
being involved with all those things you
just have to change who you are and what
you are and what you want conscious mind
versus programs subconscious mind
and when you understand this you become
empowered and I say empowered to do what
I say create Heaven on Earth and then
people think oh you die and go to heaven
I go boy is that a big mistake because
you're going to get to the Pearly Gates
Saint Peter's going to be there and he
says well
how was your experience on Heaven he
said what do you mean is that you were
on earth right that's Heaven why that's
where you came to create what did you
create I go oh
I don't want to wait to the end man
my my mother remarried when she was
relatively older and she married this
guy who was I said curmudgeony guy he
was not really a happy guy or anything
he lived to be like 95 96 or something
he had cancer my mother took care of him
at home the last week of his life
essentially wasn't there he was just
comatose more or less in the bed and
then two days before he died he all of a
sudden his eyes opened up it was there
and he looked at my mother and he said I
didn't have any fun
and all of a sudden I just said holy
crap he's gonna die in two days and he
woke up today he didn't have any fun I
said that's not me babe because when I
finished it's going to be that was great
let's do it again
rule number four is reprogram your
subconsciousness how effective is your
conscious mind at overriding the
subconscious I say it works five percent
of the time with a miniature computer
and I go wow that's your problem
I go the only way you can override the
program is not play the program that's
when we said stay Mindful and then we
then said well that's going to be
difficult because we have to think
so there's only one way out
no no don't keep it a secret tell
everybody
there's only one way out
re-program the subconscious mind
and I go significance if you would put
wishes and desire programs into the
subconscious mind
that means that that program would be
operating 95 of the Day meaning
whether your conscious mind is in
control saying these are my wishes and
desires or the conscious minds thinking
then the subconscious mind comes in and
said these are my wishes and desires
then guess what then 100 of your life
your living wishes and desires
and therefore all of a sudden then the
the the the work has to come back to
each of us as individuals each of us got
programmed each of us is manifesting
that program we give up our power in
many of the programs the fine example is
you were sick as a kid and just like
your parents and any other family
members when you were sick you went to
the doctor
I go that's a habit I said what does it
mean it says you learned this in the
first seven years the program it says
when you're sick you give up this power
and you go to that doctor and you accept
the doctor as the power of over you
because when it came to health it's like
no no you don't do it the doctor doesn't
that's the program I say so what's the
point you have given up power over the
control of your life and have given it
to the truths quote unquote offered by
the doctor I go significance I go
the doctor misreads your diagnosis and
then tells you oh I'm sorry you only
have three months left to live
then I go significance
95 percent of the day the program says
the doctor is the you know
the correct one the truth what do I know
the doctor knows what do I know so 95 of
the day then your belief system is going
to do what take the words of the doctor
and manifest them as truth I go what's
that mean well you're going to die in
about three months I go from what I go
hey that was a misdiagnosis you're still
gonna die because your belief system
will manifest in illness that will
terminate the cancer for example is not
due to any genes there's no Gene that
causes cancer
the genes are correlated with cancer and
I go what causes cancer I say disharmony
and repressed anger is one of the big
ones I go so then I say the genes didn't
cost I say no
so I said then what caused it I say my
Consciousness I say what repressed anger
you know and I go so what I say well
change Consciousness and guess what
you can go into remission
the cancer will go away as soon as you
change the Consciousness and all of a
sudden it's like I thought I was a
victim of the genes I said that's a
program
and that is totally incorrect
because as quantum physics says
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences and as the new biology which
I'm familiar with called epigenetics is
how Consciousness controls the genetics
and all of a sudden I say oh well then
biology and quantum physics now share
the same story yeah you're creating this
and the idea is then if you look at the
creation you're not happy with it don't
go out and blame the creation
because you never saw that you were
participating in a way invisible to you
that led to this expression
if you want to change it you have to
change you
and then the environment will change
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is overcome the
fear of mortality the fear
which is human specific
is the fear of mortality there's no
other organism that knows it's going to
die
and I say that fear
is what then we gave up our power to
have somebody assuage that fear it's
like oh it's not so bad or whatever you
know we we bought what religion why did
we buy religion well I want to tell you
about what happens after you die the big
mystery and I say oh then all of a
sudden guess what they made the program
for my life I go who the hell are you to
make a program for my life well I bought
it because I was in fear and fear means
I have no power and when I have no power
I'm going to seek someone who says they
have the power and then I'm going to
accommodate what they do and so people
join in a religion because they have the
fear of the afterlife well I'm going to
tell you the beautiful part about my
research was I didn't believe in
spirituality okay I had no to me
afterlife was um chemicals and when I
die I go back into chemistry you know
that's what it is
but when I understood this said oh my
God
I'm an immortal entity I'm a spiritual
field quantum mechanics a field
and all of a sudden I started to realize
oh my goodness I I I have no fear why
I'm not gonna die I'm not even in here
so how the hell am I going to die and
once that fear
was gone my life was radically different
I tell you why
because we all live with that biological
imperative that says I'm afraid to die
and I said but what if you're not afraid
to die what if you don't see death as an
end what if you see is just a transition
into another way and all of a sudden I
say what the consequence of that is no
fear I said then what does that mean I
said then I'm more powerful because it
was the fear that took away my power and
if I don't have fear then you can't
scare me and I don't I'm not scared and
I don't care about your rules about
afterlife because I have my own
understanding now you don't have to try
and tell me about afterlife I know what
I am I'm a spirit I'm an energy field
rule number six is boost your immune
system the immune system protects you
from a threat on the inside yeah but if
the Tigers chasing you who cares about
the threat on the inside I got a
bacterial infection and a sabertooth
tiger chasing me I think where should I
put my energy in the hell with the
infection the tiger catches you the
infection's not a problem anymore so
very important fact profoundly everyone
listen
stress hormones specifically shut down
the immune system because the taking
care of the inside is not as important
as taking care of the whole thing
running away uh in fact stress hormones
are so good at this that when doctors
want to transplant an organ from person
a into person B the recipient of that
organ is given stress hormones before
the operation because it reduces the
function of the immune system which
would be rejecting The graft and so you
don't want the immune system to reject a
graph so you give them stress hormones
which what shuts down the immune system
I go well guess what in today's world
just watch the news for a moment and all
of a sudden your immune system is going
yeah so that's number two so number one
stress hormone shut down growth because
feeding the viscera for its functions
not worthy of running away I need to get
the blood into the arms and legs again
to conserve energy because look the
immune system uses a lot of energy if
you've ever been sick sometimes you
don't have the energy to get out of bed
so it's like well when it's operating it
could drain you of energy yeah but if
you're being chased by a saber-tooth
tiger
the hell with the immune system uh and
so you shut that down so those are two
insults to the system in other words if
I'm not under stress I'm nourishing my
body and I'm encouraging my immune
system I'm staying healthy but the
moment I'm under stress
both of those things shut down and I'm
ready to to fight or flight uh and then
I said well there's a third one I call
that adding insult to injury and the
answer about what that means is this the
brain has the forebrain where conscious
thinking is conscious thinking and the
Haim brain which is uh like habit and
reflex Behavior conscious thinking is
slow I mean imagine your car is going
out of control and spinning and I say
stay in the conscious mind it's like oh
I say yeah but the moment the car starts
to go out of control the stress hormones
go in remember I told you they squeezed
the blood vessels in the gut they
squeeze the blood vessels in the
forebrain I say why because it pushes
the blood
to the hind brain which is a million
times more powerful than the forebrain
is a machine processor and I go so why
is it relent I go because the moment the
car is going out of control is oh wow
turning the wheel hitting the pedals
you're doing everything Beyond fast so
fast okay yes so
when you're in a stressful situation
thinking is slow
and therefore the system doesn't want
you to be slow it needs you to go boom
react reflect right away so the blood
vessels from the same chemistry
squeezing the blood vessels down the gut
squeeze the blood vessels here push it
to the hindbrain we become less
intelligent when we're under stress
because now we're reactive and it gets
to a point that sometimes they're so
afraid that you take care of me and then
we give up we give up control to the guy
with the bigger stick yes you'll take
care of me well that means we're a
victim victim means we're powerless I go
when stress hormones are in the system
the only Power you have is to run and I
go and relevance about that is very is
very simple and that is that
it was only designed with saber-toothed
tigers of mine I go why is that real
they say well the Sabertooth tiger is
chasing I go yeah and I'm running like
crazy I got blood in my arms and legs I
got all the energy and I say yeah but if
you escape that tiger in a few minutes
of running
then there's no more threat
and then all of a sudden the stress
hormones are gone and then you're back
into growth and everything else
but today stress is 24 7 365 a human
body was never designed to be
maintaining a stress situation because
it suppresses the Vitality of the system
and in today's world with the idea of
covid everyone's afraid I go and guess
what the one thing you wanted was your
immune system to work and the one thing
that's not working because you're afraid
is the immune system I go the more fear
people have the sicker they become yes
and this is a wake-up call that says man
we have to stop listening to that fear
of drum they keep beating the drum every
or everybody's gonna die I don't know
to die
there are people who are indeed
vulnerable because they're already
stressed immune system people that live
in stress are already open to a problem
uh older people whose immune system is
are not working up to the fullest
capability they're under threat because
their immune system is already
compromised and then there's the people
with what are called comorbidities they
go what are they I say these are
stressors on the system that are chronic
overweight is one of the biggest ones in
the serious cases of covid 78 of those
serious patients were overweight why
overweight is a challenge to the system
and you're already challenging your
immune system before the damn virus
showed up so that's a big problem uh
Diabetes Type 2 meaning that's a stress
World diabetes is a stressor that's in
the system the more stressors that you
have going
the less effect of your immune system is
so it turns out here's a number
unfortunately Americans
UH 60 of Americans have at least one
comorbidity they're slightly compromised
okay but 40 and this is where the issue
comes from have two or more simultaneous
comorbidities these are people that are
ripe for infection why their immune
systems are already compromised before
the damn virus showed up so it's like
well then I'm am I afraid of coven I
said well if you're a healthy person no
if you're you know if you're a
compromised person then you should be
taking care of yourself I don't have to
take care of myself you have to take
care of yourself because you're the one
that's open and yet we want everybody to
put on the mask and everybody to get the
vaccines I go
that that
stuff I was going to say a bad word that
stuff
is not valid I go to me it's not Val I
say
the country of Gibraltar 100
of that population has been vaccinated
and guess what Delta went through there
like a plague man and I say yeah but
they were all vaccinated I go yeah
because the vaccine doesn't work I go
well yeah but now all we're Chronicles
no the vaccine doesn't work and they say
well get your booster shot I said get
the booster shot I didn't even work the
damn first time it takes a second time
and so the real issue is this
we have to take care of our health
uh and not wait for other people to
protect me from them if I'm a vulnerable
person it's my responsibility to take
care of my health rule number seven is
create with your mind mind controls not
just what genes are being activated but
mine can alter the blueprint I can make
3 000 different proteins from the same
blueprint just based on how I see the
world so all of a sudden it says wow we
are very powerful We're The Architects
and we can create help we can also
create disease because we're the creator
of it okay so now comes the the big part
and that is this
to me the most valid science on this
planet is quantum physics quantum
physics I say that because uh back in
1927 when it was theoretical they came
up with a whole bunch of things you know
Albert Einstein Max Planck Heisenberg
they came up with a theory of how
everything worked well it's nearly a
hundred years and guess what almost all
of their theories are totally accurate
so we have a deep deep understanding of
quantum physics Consciousness is
creating our life experience principle
number one it was back in 1927 Max
Planck founder of one of the founders
said the mind is the Matrix of all
matter that's where the movie The Matrix
comes from rule number eight is
acknowledge what you want do you see
value in going backwards in other words
in Psychotherapy or in going back to the
past no
why wouldn't I why didn't I say value in
that and I said because when you go back
and Replay that problem yeah
you've exercised that problem again you
have pushed the buttons that created the
problem in the first place that's why
they have so many boxes of tissues in
the in the psych office because you're
going to cry your eyes out why because
you're going to be replaying the trauma
of what caused the problem and this is
the cool part
it no longer exists it's not there
anymore except for you carrying it with
you and there's a point where I say well
then why should I go back and repeat
this because it's just going to cause a
replay of the same program which
reinforces that program I go I don't
care about the past I care about here I
am today I want to go this way what do I
want today I don't care about what
happened back there not that I should
forget about it because I don't want to
replay it again but it doesn't control
me anymore because I say replaying that
is just the you know putting a in the
old days they had records you guys don't
know about but they had knee record and
if you keep the needle gets deeper in
the group like we don't want to play it
again so it's irrelevant to go back I
like it there's a story of a two
Buddhist monks a monks are not the the
male monks are not allowed to touch
women and these two monks are walking
along the path and they come to a river
and there's a one women all dressed up
in her wedding finery and she's crying
and crying and it's what's wrong she
says well I can't get across the water
and you know I'll ruin my clothes and so
one monk just picture up
walks across drops her on the other side
and then the two monks walk down the
street about half hour 45 minutes later
the one that didn't pick her up turns to
him he said you kicked up a woman back
there
and then the other monk says I put her
down 45 minutes ago you're still
carrying her
and if you get the story the story is
this
it was over
the history is over do I want to repeat
it no so there's a way of seeing what it
was but I don't have to repeat it
because I have to say what is it I want
not what is it I don't want a lot of
people I don't want this I go yeah but
what is it you want
people have more problems answering what
it is they want than saying what they
don't want and the important part about
this is you can only move into the
future that you want by acknowledging
what you want not saying I don't want
that anymore I said well that didn't I
didn't give you your future uh and and
so yes there are ways to reprogram the
subconscious uh and when you do your
life will change in permanently rule
number nine is study Physics as you
understand the terms quantum physics and
quantum mechanics or Newtonian physics
or Newtonian mechanics what you see is
that physics and mechanics are synonyms
so physics really means the mechanisms
by which the universe operates and the
new physics quantum physics was
something that I really wasn't into nor
were any of my colleagues in the medical
school we were all trained in Newtonian
physics and the difference between the
two is very profound Newtonian physics
says the world that we live in the
universe we live in is as a machine made
out of mechanical Parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces change the pieces
change the operation That's the basis of
medicine we look at a human body it's a
machine made out of physical parts when
it's not working right change the parts
by buying chemicals and drugs and that's
the way that conventional medicine
operates when I started to read the
quantum physics I realized oh my
goodness the the whole foundation of the
universe is not based on a mechanical
physical Universe it's based on the
invisible energy called the field so
let's say if I hold a magnet right here
in front of you and you can see the
magnet but what you can see is the
invisible magnetic field and so what it
says is well we are physical things in
our world like physical bodies we're
immersed in fields electro magnetic
fields magnetic fields itself all kinds
of fields like telephone cell phone
Fields television Fields radio Fields
whole ranges
what is the difference between the
Newtonian physics and the quantum
physics is this Newtonian physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you want to understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by Albert
Einstein and it's simple it goes the
field is the soul governing agency of
the particle in other words in the world
of invisible things fields and particles
matter
it's the field that gives shape to the
matter and this is the basis of quantum
physics this becomes relevant it says
okay here's the physical particles of my
body why are they in a healthy state or
why could they be in a sick State that's
the physical expression and the answer
is well to understand that don't look at
the body you have to understand the
invisible forces in the field
it's fun because if you think about when
when of course when you were young at
some point you must have had like iron
filings and sprinkled it around a magnet
and all of a sudden you saw the iron
filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field
well quantum physics would look at this
pattern and try to explain how come all
the iron filings fell in this pattern
without recognizing that the field
exists in other words can you explain
why the iron filings have this shape if
you don't recognize a magnetic field the
answer is absolutely not what's the
nature of it the body and its cells are
like iron filings medicine is trying to
understand the nature of the body by
looking at the iron filings and quantum
physics says if you don't understand
that invisible field you can't ever
understand what's happening in the body
angle number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is get in the
flow when you think about someone who's
an artist and they're creating a
musician a chef a chef a chef or or in
love like you're in the flow right so
you're just because you're you're
thinking yeah you're not thinking you're
doing and it doesn't mean there's not
participation it just means that you're
not thinking of the future you're kind
of just the time and space sort of
change like you you lose track of time
yeah that kind of stuff yeah not
thinking means not diverting to the
subconscious meaning you stay in
conscious creativity yeah not this
creativity his wishes and desires so a
chef uh is so involved with the cooking
and paying attention all the details
they're not thinking and I say well what
does that mean they're not coming from
program they're coming from creativity
okay the artist the chef uh the race car
driver yeah
thinking man uh you know we're in it
we're gone
and the subconscious is much faster than
the conscious and that's why in times of
Emergency the conscious is too slow to
help us and that's why we jump to it but
then the problem is whatever Behavior
you're going to express while you're in
that subconscious was a program that you
had a positive or negative well up to 60
percent of the programs that you
downloaded are not positive they're
disempowering programs
the world is in a state of evolution and
what I mean by evolution is not a
physical Evolution humans are not going
to change into something different the
evolution that we're really experiencing
now is an evolution in consciousness
the Consciousness that has in the past
separated us as individuals
Consciousness that has been programmed
with a belief that life is a struggle
and that we're out here uh to survive we
have to be in competition with each
other and undercut and undermine and we
were acting as individuals looking for
our own individual power
but in today's world there's a new
understanding that the evolution is an
evolution of Consciousness an evolution
of an expansion of we are more than just
these physical entities
that there is an energy involved in
Newtonian physics the conventional ones
that most people have learned atoms are
physical particles like little granules
but in 1925 physicists came to another
understanding because they said so what
are those particles made out of you
called atoms and they went inside and
they found they were smaller so-called
particles electrons protons and neutrons
but that still wasn't the quest because
what are they made out of and that's
when the world changed because when
Quantum physicists started to say what
is an electron or a proton or a neutron
made out of it's made out of energy not
physical no substance and atom is like a
nano tornado a spinning force field
there's an illusion that we are physical
entities you're an energy field
and I go so what the heck difference
does that make and I go well here's the
interesting part particles I can
separate here's a particle here's a
particle let's talk about one particle
energy just mixes all together I'm
sitting in a field of energy right now
so if I'm made out of energy which I am
does it mean that the edge of my energy
stops right here and the answer is no in
quantum mechanics I'm an energy field
wherever I go I'm like a broadcast
broadcasting and energy wherever you are
right now you're broadcasting energy and
so in a Newtonian world we grew up with
this is separate from this and that's
separate from this and I go in a quantum
mechanical world nothing is separate
everything is an energy field with no
borders through it so what I do in my
world is not just what I do in my world
what I do in my world is broadcast
through everything else and if it
resonates or is in harmony with you my
energy can affect your energy or my
energy can actually cancel your energy
everything is interconnected the chair
I'm sitting on is energy the air I'm in
breathing with is energy I'm energy your
energy we're all connected in this
energy but the fact is energies are
Communications
and we vibrate and broadcast just like a
radio we're broadcasting who we are out
into the field and we alter what's going
on it is beyond language it's a
communication it has nothing to do with
words it's an energy that's available if
you just want to feel it and I think
that's the big issue feelings because
feelings are telling you you feel good
yes I'm having more energy you feel bad
you feel weak I'm having less energy I
say why is it relevant it's more
powerful than words energy can tell me
am I with people that are supporting me
because I feel good around them or do I
have a little quasi feeling of this it
doesn't feel right to me so we have a
new world that we're coming into and
it's based on the energy and if you can
read energy
you are being guided if you can't read
energy you don't know what's going to
happen next if you follow the words
that's where we have been sold the bill
of goods where people say yeah these are
good words what do you think and then
I'll buy that because the words and I
say yeah but if you ever stop long
enough to say how do you feel about it
not how what you hear about it it
empowers you beyond anything in the
world so the wake-up call now is yeah
listen to people fine but feel feel that
people feel where you are feel is this
what I want to do do I want to do this
or I want to do that I say you can ask
your head and rationalize anything but I
say don't ask that question in your head
ask the question of your heart your
heart is the monitor of the vibration
your heart will give you an answer more
accurate about anything in your world
than your rational thinking will you're
being chased by a saber-toothed tiger I
say you you need energy to to survive
you have to run I said where's the
energy going to go I said well Energy's
in the blood that's what carries the
energy I say when the stress hormones
come in because the tiger is chasing you
it does several things it shuts off the
blood flow to the the gut the viscera
all the organs pancreas stomach
intestines I go it shuts off the blood
supply I say why I don't need to fix and
maintain the body if the tiger is going
to catch me and then I don't that's a
waste of my energy I want all the energy
go to my arms and legs Escape so I say
stress hormones shut off the the
mechanism of the viscera the growth and
maintenance of the body while you're
being chased I said what else and here
comes the one that you were bringing up
when when we're really sick
you don't have a lot of energy to even
get out of bed because the immune system
uses a lot of energy to keep you healthy
I go so I'm being chased by a tiger
and I have a bacterial infection so I'm
putting energy in to run away and
putting energy into the infection I go
why do you worry about the infection
because if the tiger catches you the
infection is not a problem anymore
you're done okay so the this is the
point you brought up and this is the
most important point for the audience to
understand
stress hormones shut off the immune
system so that the energy can be used to
run away from the tiger before being
used to fight the bacteria
and this is the most important
understanding because stress is the
cause of over 90 percent of illness on
this planet everyone thinks genes are
causing the illness I go less than one
percent of illnesses connected to genes
ninety percent of illness is stress
because when you put the stress hormones
in what do they do they shut off the
maintenance of the body they shut off
the immune system and they even shut off
the intelligence
if the conscious brain the one up in the
front that's connected to you your
person is a slow processor like a slow
computer
the subconscious is like a super fast
if you're being chased by a tiger it's
not the time to think of oh oh
oh I go no no run and so the stress
hormones shut down the blood vessels in
the forebrain where the Consciousness is
pushes the blood with the energy to the
hindbrain where reflexes and reaction no
thinking because thinking is slow so I
say so then stress hormones do three
things number one they shut off the
growth and maintenance of the body
number two they shut down the immune
system which protects you from internal
problem and number three they make you
less intelligent
look at the look at the world today the
stress levels are overriding as I said
90 percent of illnesses straight stress
not genetics it's lifestyle it's the
fear it's not living in harmony they
don't have enough good music to bring
Harmony into their world they're they're
on edge
I go well that automatically compromises
your health less than one listen less
than one percent of disease is connected
to genes I go where the hell's all the
disease coming from
90 Plus
of disease
is stress
and and all of a sudden oh so I said
well you can relieve all the take all
the cancer cells out I said did you get
rid of the stress no oh well then guess
what it's coming back
because that the the cells didn't cause
the problem they are a symptom of a
problem
and all diseases like cardiovascular
disease 90 has nothing to do with genes
you're not living in harmony you're
living in fear a lot of it has a fear is
the greatest cause of stress because
fear means I'm powerless that's what
fear means oh my God something's coming
I I'm a victim I am powerless somebody
help me and then the pharmaceutical
company comes and goes we're here to
help you
I got another line of BS I believe it
says
pharmaceutical company isn't here to
help you it's a company it's a
corporation I say give me the rule
number one rule in law when you make a
corporation what is the number one rule
in the corporation's leadership and the
answer is your job is to make a profit
for the shareholder that's number one if
a corporation is not making a profit for
the shareholder then it falls apart
doesn't work anymore so I said well how
do you make a profit for the shareholder
I say God make a lot of money I go well
making a lot of money does that mean
you're going to help a lot of people I
go well tell them we'll help them we'll
sell them with drugs and they'll buy the
drugs and then we're going to make a lot
of money I'll say do the drugs really
work I go how many people are out there
because the doctor said your blood
pressure is high or your cholesterol
level is high and we're going to have to
give you stat statin drugs I go how long
do I do I have to take a prescription of
satin drugs and then the doctor goes how
long do you want to live oh you went to
that then take stat and drugged your
whole life I go
I can't take my whole life I said are
they gonna help me now comes the truth
statin drugs only help three out of 100
people
97 people out of 100 have no positive
effect from certain drugs in fact over
20 of those people will have side
effects that are disastrous so wait I
took the statin drugs to help me with my
cholesterol level three people are going
to be helped 20 people are going to get
sicker I go well maybe we shouldn't sell
the statin drugs they go are you kidding
me man that's a prescription for life
that means we have a customer for a life
and I go nobody paid attention to the
side effects being more dangerous than
the the healing effect that I go people
don't care because they're told whatever
the advertisement told them drug
companies they don't give a damn why
because the 97 people that Deb no
positive effect from satins are going to
pay them every day of their life to take
a satin drug I said is you're going to
help them I go nope but they're going to
pay for it every day and the drug
companies like yay
I could sell lots of sun and drugs and
you know what they did to sell more
drugs because there was a cholesterol
level and it said if you're above this
cholesterol level you need a Statin drug
okay then what'd they do they kept
changing the cholesterol level over time
it was no no you have to have less
cholesterol oh all of a sudden it said
people that you know had a certain level
of cholesterol below the required part
no I don't have to take statin drugs
then I said no no you need a cholesterol
down here oh now that many more people
are going to take statin drugs every
time they lowered the amount of
cholesterol to another level there's a
whole new cohort of people that are
going to buy the Statin drug because oh
it used to be oh that cholesterol level
was okay now it's not okay now you got
to take the drug because they kept
lowering the level and every time they
lower the level there's a million new
customers for statin drugs did it help
absolutely not the side effects were far
greaters like five seven times greater
side effects than healing just to begin
with a very interesting concept that
um
judeo-christianity has provided the
large population of the world with a
belief that Genesis occurred and God
created the planet and the water and
then the animals and the plants and
after all this creation then God said
let's add some humans to the mix so we
didn't come from that creation we were
added to the Earth
science comes in and also separates us
from the planet because conventional
science based on what is called
Newtonian physics we are physical
particles separate from each other no
we're all separate pieces and we lost
the understanding that the word Gaia
is a living organism the Earth is a cell
we are connected to everything we've
lost that Vision we feel that we are a
peace in a in a bunch of pieces and as I
said are we going to be safe or are we
going to be afraid in this and I said
then we want to protect ourselves and if
you understand the breathing of most
people it's very shallow it's right up
here why I don't want to take too much
of the outside in I'm protecting myself
but as you said we we still need oxygen
so we breathe in a little bit of oxygen
but we want to be separate
and the simple reality is those beliefs
are totally false we were created with
everything we are created from
everything there is no separation
between us and the world in which we
live
and so when we are breathing very
shallow we are actually remember I said
protection close yourself down shallow
breathing closing yourself down when you
start to learn to take in the breath of
life you are opening yourself to the
entire world around us
and that opening of the world makes us
part of this world not A Separate Peace
from one another
so breathing becomes a very important
part of am I hiding from the World by
just breathing a little tiny bit or can
I take in this breath and become part of
this Oneness that we are your separation
is where all the problems of life come
from
your breathing can open you up
to this entire world to take it in you
are this world you are every bit of this
you're a reflection of everything out
there you came from that
so basically can we stop the protection
that we think is helping us but it's the
protection that is killing us
and breathing can I take this in
can I take the world in yes
and I can Thrive and so when we start to
let go of that protection the breathing
will start to go from shallow chest to
abdominal because I'm taking in the
world with every breath I'm taking in
the energy of the world with every
breath and that is what makes us whole
you have shallow breathing you have fear
all of a sudden you cannot be whole
anymore
and so we come here to learn to take
power back
and and oh my God Closing word yoga
there's Bruce Lipton has two two lives
Bruce Lipton the guy who lives in the
house and goes to the store and all that
stuff okay and Bruce Lipton a scientist
I go what's the difference
I say Bruce Lipton a scientist knows
that from science we are facing our own
extinction because of our own human
behavior Bruce Lipton has a scientist
also knows this if you want to create a
world that we can live in and sustain
ourselves and be healthy we have to
change our Behavior because our behavior
is causing the problem so I also know
what does this mean it says the
structure has to break
to build a better structure a new
civilization because the foundation of
this civilization is creating all the
problems it's the culture and the way we
live with fear and hate and violence and
all that I go a garden which we came
from a garden is the height of
cooperation and we we live in the height
of of war and violence and all this
stuff we live in competition
and the idea is this then the belief
system of this civilization the fear the
competition the war all that stuff
that's part of our creation because
we're creating this physics
let's say you want to change the world
you've got to change the creation and we
have to break this structure because the
structure is perpetuating the problem
yes and it has to go in a chaos phase
let's break down yeah that's right so
science Bruce goes yep it has to break
down because that's how we're going to
build a new one and then Bruce the guy
who lives here goes what a mess is a
crazy mess of the scary
I'm living in Crazy mess but then Bruce
Lipton science comes in and says you
have to do this because the way you have
been living is causing the problem you
have to change
and that's easy to say but if you're out
there in the world as a working person
and everything and you have to
experience it's like it's falling apart
I go that scares people scares people
stress hormones stress hormones stop
thinking and listen to whatever they
said on a TV or the web don't think shut
down your your health why because I'm
running from that tiger because I am
scared and the point is then the health
issues got worse just watching the news
you walk away with the stress hormones
coming in they're like oh you just all
of a sudden made your system worse
because the stress hormones are going to
compromise you the most important thing
about transcending a program as I
mentioned before is identifying what the
program is and that's why I wanted to
give people an insight to their own
programming by just reviewing their life
and recognizing things you like come in
because you have a program things you
desire that don't come in is because you
have a program that doesn't support that
and I say well how do you change these
programs uh and I said there's three
fundamental ways to change a program and
it's very critical because the
subconscious mind is a habit mind the
conscious mind is a creative mind I go
what's the difference I say habit by
definition doesn't want to change I mean
if a habit changes then it's not a habit
anymore so I say first issue is this the
programs that we were downloaded with
are habits they were put into our mind
before age seven and then we just play
them like a push the button play the
program push the button play the program
not all habits are bad a matter of fact
you wouldn't like it without a
subconscious I'll give the example when
did you learn how to walk you learned
how to walk before you were two you
could be a hundred and two you're still
walking I go why that habit is there and
it doesn't change and so the first thing
we have to recognize habits are not like
open hey just change me you actually
have to like push a record button to get
into that habit I go well how do you get
a habit I said well how did we get a
habit in our life I said for the first
seven years we were in a state of
consciousness called Theta which is
hypnosis and we downloaded it and the
relevance about that is uh Theta is a
lower vibration than conscious which is
Alpha and focused Consciousness Beta And
I go so why is irrelevant because when
we are working like right now we're in
beta High Focus Consciousness School
room kind of working like that but when
we go home and relax the vibration slows
down that's called Alpha so we're in a
calmer consciousness
but what people have to recognize is
this the moment you close your eyes like
I'm just going to sleep Consciousness
switch went off I'm not in an alpha I
just dropped into Theta I go well
Consciousness is closed but Theta is
hypnosis so if you put earphones on and
you go to bed uh and you put the
earphones on and there's a program
playing through those earphones of
things that you want to be true in your
life uh you might hear some of the
program while you're still awake but the
moment Consciousness disconnects you're
in a zone of theta before you go to the
lowest vibration Delta which is absolute
sleep so every night there's a window of
opportunity putting earphones on as soon
as your conscious mind goes to sleep the
subconscious mind is going to take
whatever's coming in those earphones and
begin to download them because that is
hypnosis so that's self-hypnosis but
that by age seven changes because by age
seven now we spend more time in
Consciousness than in Theta uh and I go
but we still learn things you learn how
to drive a car you learn how to practice
with an instrument you learn all these
things I say why is it relevant in the
answer is something like this how did
you create a habit practice you
practiced it so the second way of
changing a program is practice a new
life if you don't like the one you have
uh yeah I like a new age of people fake
it till you make it I go yeah what does
that mean I say well I'm a miserable
person I want to be happy so I said but
you're not happy I said yeah but fake it
what does that mean I say all day long
anytime you can just consciously pass by
you say oh I am happy I am happy you
could be miserable I don't really care
the idea is I am happy I am happy
repetition practice is how you make
habits and so if you keep saying all day
long I'm happy I'm happy and you say it
for a period of time because it's habit
practice there's a day you wake up and
you already started happy because the
program is already in there you don't
even have to do it anymore when a
raindrop hits a pond
the ripples that come off of the
raindrop
or the shape of water
but the water was shaped by the energy
from The Rock so the energy is now
visualized not the not the Ripple itself
it's the shape of the Ripple so we have
all these waves and I go so what and I
say well when you look at a pond and
it's raining out the first thing you
notice that all the ripples are
converging with each other and they're
modifying each other and that so
basically everything is connected and
everything is energy but the final shape
is really dependent on the the waves and
their patterns when they come together
some energy comes together and it
enhances power that's called construct
of interference and in human in human
terms that is good vibes yeah mainly
because urine energy pattern and if
you're in an energy field that is in
harmony with you two energies and
Harmony come together and they ha they
add up
so that we get more power okay so there
are fields that are really good and you
can feel them Good Vibes and as I said
how what's Good Vibes I feel more power
being around you not that I'm touching
you or anything at that level because
you're rating radiating energy I'm
radiating energy but if we're radiating
harmonic energy we're in musical terms
synchrony absolutely Harmony Harmony
right and that's enhancing of power but
then there's another form of energy and
this other form of energy is uh let's
say this wave is going up and this wave
is going down when this one's going down
this one's going up so they're not in
harmony okay uh and they're interfering
and it's called destructive interference
which is the opposite of when we just
said two harmonies come together they're
interfering but it's called constructive
because there's more power but two
energies can come together in a
destructive form and cancel out
everything uh and like um in technology
they have earphones that are called
noise canceling they got all this noise
you put the earphones on the noise
disappears I said what where'd the noise
going the interesting part was the
earphones have a microphone
they're recording the sound of the
environment the vibration
and then through the electronics it
plays the sound back but just out of
phase so they're not both in harmony now
one is going up and the other's going
down they're just out of phase but that
when you add up two out of phase waves
that's cancellation
to make you know uh uh those kind of
earphones for example noise canceling is
it's not you subtracted something from a
noise you added a noise to a noise you
added a vibration to a vibration so now
I say oh well now there's two there's a
range energies can come together and
enhance and multiply and be more
powerful
or energies that are not in harmony can
come together and cancel each other out
okay constructive interference
destructive interference but in human
terms is
constructive interference Good Vibes
more power and destructive interference
bad by I want peace under the Earth and
all the rest of fighting all over the
place that means nothing
but if I get enough people
to say we want peace on Earth and we get
to that number and as Lynn said it
didn't start with a massive number
started with a small number but that
number grew why Buckminster Fuller
singer says Build a Better World people
will come from that world to visit your
world and what Lynn is showing we can
build a better world and why is it
increasing a number of people because
people are saying I want what Linz has
it always reminds me of the movie
the table what walking her goes I want
what she has well this is what Lynn and
Brian offer they have something to say
they have something I want what she has
why because it's empowering why
it changes your Consciousness your
Consciousness is creating
if the creation doesn't look good you
don't change the world you change the
Consciousness the world then changes
because of your creativity and that's
why
um Lin's work to me is so important to
get people to wake up and say miracles
happen when you get enough tuning Forks
together and how many well apparently
eight tuning Forks is good to change
I mean the first step the first one was
so small and Irrelevant in one sense but
so powerful was I'm working on this
going oh my God I I've been programmed
and if I if I follow the program it's a
good program great but if it's a bad
program I'm going downhill and I
remember I was in my office at the
University and one of my faculty
colleagues came in that day and said
okay Bruce what are you bringing to the
faculty party on Saturday night what I
want to tell you faculty party might as
well just kill yourself you go there and
everybody's sitting around with a drink
not talking to each other because they
don't really like it
okay and I thought about I work all damn
week
why should I go to a stupid faculty
party and waste the entire time where I
had freedom to create something I would
love to do so on you know just came
right out of my mouth oh I'm sorry I
didn't realize it was this weekend I
have other plans I can oh I can't I
can't go this weekend I didn't have
plans but I just said that and he looked
at me like you're not going to The
Faculty party I go no and he walked out
and the moment he walked out I went oh
Saturday night for
me
what can I get rid of that I've been
programmed that this is what we do
socially even though it takes away
character quality joy out of life and I
started to eliminate them and say wait
I'm creating this I don't want to give
up my creation because socially this is
what we should do I said I got my life
man I want to live it and I have been
living a heaven on Earth life
ever since those days why well with the
help of my partner Margaret who I met at
50 so 40 as a kid's age at 50 uh uh and
she she was quite aware of all the stuff
that I talked about we changed we
rewrote our programs beautiful and we
put together what 26 years now oh my God
a honeymoon every day I wake up hey I'm
still alive I've got a great partner we
have a great life I work every day I
wake up it's like wow I'm still here I'm
enjoying every day that I can get it's
called the honeymoon effect
forever wow how'd you do that I say get
rid of the programs that took the joy
away and replace them with programs that
give you Joy what we now know is the
conscious mind if you stay in the
conscious mind
you have power
but if the conscious mind is thinking it
is not using its power to interfere with
the uh and act with the outer World
thinking is using the power to go to the
inner world so a thought is not outside
a thought is inside yeah but the
conscience is reading their thoughts so
I said what does that mean I said well
the conscience is helping me create this
world oh wait wait the moment I'm
thinking
I have to take that Consciousness
redirected not look out but redirect it
because thinking is inside so I said
well what does that mean I said well the
moment you were thinking you were not
creating your world at this moment I
said what does that mean I say if you're
driving the car and all of a sudden you
start thinking what it means is you're
not looking out the window anymore you
are now looking inside because answers
for thoughts are on the inside then you
go oh my God you stop looking out the
window the car is going to crash and I
go
cool apart or not yeah the subconscious
is autopilot so the moment Consciousness
is not paying attention
the subconscious Takes the Wheel
but now comes the problem the
subconscious is not you it's the program
so if I got bad driving instructions
then when the subconscious takes the
wheel as autopilot it's going to take me
down the road to ruin it's not going to
take me to where conscious says I want
to have this wonderful success but my
program is you're not worthy you're not
smart enough you're not deserving so
when that program grabs the wheel it's
not going to take me to success it's
going to take me to where the program
goes so if I disempower you in your
programming and 95 percent of your life
comes from that
the rest of your life is struggle and
it's not because you couldn't create it
it's just you didn't realize that this
subconscious guy is working 95 percent
of the time and you don't see it and
this is where how come life seems to be
a struggle from the outside coming in
when it's like oh my God you didn't get
it you're creating both success and
you're creating failure it's not coming
from outside please listen to this
a negative thought is equally powerful
in controlling the biology so as much as
a positive thought can heal you a
negative thought can kill you it can
make any disease you can have a negative
thought about cancer and manifest cancer
you have no no genes or even cancer
related genes and it's like where the
hell did it come from you are creating
your biology as a compliment to what you
see
so if you see a positive world then
you're getting Positive Vibes coming in
and it feels really great and if you
live in a negative world or one you
believe to be negative then the cells
are inside cowering going oh my God it's
not safe out there uh and and so my
cells are just adjusting to my
perception so changing your perception
is like well where's that and I go
that's your mind humans have morality
we're supposed to anyway you know don't
kill things okay uh we're supposed to
have morality
but corporations have no morality they
just have a mission how much money can I
make that is the mission by law of what
a corporation is so I say then that's
why they can do anything let's destroy
the environment if we can make enough
money
and all of a sudden you start to see the
leadership of this world is not really
caring about what the individuals want
they want to appease the money making
part and then the laws come down and and
if it conflicts with a corporate law
then screw the people let's give the
corporation their due and that's once we
gave up and we said humans are like uh
corporations are like humans and have
the power of a human I go no they don't
they have no morality they're nothing
like a human at all uh and uh and we
gave them all the power
and this is a wake-up call for all of us
that said
who's caring for you
you know I love that they always talk
about the friendly Banker
when's the banker friendly the banker is
friendly when you have money yeah if you
don't have money a banker's not so
friendly anymore it doesn't care about
you at all you know and I go same thing
pharmaceutical company you got money
we're working with you yeah I don't care
about you if you have no money and we
lost and so the evolution we're facing
right now says we have been driven to
this by a Minds that have no uh care for
an environment hey take what you want do
what you want throw crap into the water
you know all this kind of stuff dig out
the natural resources every it's like
what's our future if you do this the
answer is it's already happening
Extinction we're not in harmony with
each other obviously and we're not in
harmony with nature
and I say well that you got two choices
here
follow the money
or follow the Harmony
and right now unfortunately this is a
tug of war and corporates are winning
because fear because once you're afraid
you give up power fear is a definition
I'm not I'm afraid like well then who's
going to help you who's got the biggest
stick yeah who's the one with the
biggest clown let's give them the power
and I'll wait here for them to fix it
and I go
they're clubbing you over that at this
point and we have to wake up I'm sorry I
went on a tirade
the subconscious mind is yours not
shared by anybody else so it's not a
common mind for for civilization it's
what you've downloaded what you learned
and how you're you know playing in your
life your conscious mind though that's
the one that is coming from the field uh
where everyone else is involved and so
Consciousness is what connects us all
subconscious is your life experiences
it's used for this lifetime uh and
something as the new science revealed to
me which I didn't really know for most
of my life is that uh We Are Spiritual
entities I I was teaching genes you know
and now I start to recognize from the
physics that we Are Spiritual entities
uh and that uh the body is like a
television set my spirit is the
broadcast
should say television is dead and I go
yeah television is dead but is the
broadcast still there and the answer of
course it's still there and I said yes
this is the same thing with the human we
are not in this body we are receiving a
broadcast of field in terms of the
science of quantum physics there's a
field that's playing through us and I go
so if your body dies the field didn't
die it's still there it's like that blew
my mind because I said oh my God you
can't die you're not even in here and
then the The Joy about that was you also
come back again when another embryo has
the same set of what are called
self-receptors that are reading that
field for you each of us has our own set
of these self-receptors These are
proteins no two people have the same
sense so each of us is receiving a
different energy broadcast then let's
just turn it back for a second to the
subconscious mind the subconscious mind
is learned in this lifetime from the
experiences as we have in this lifetime
but when you pass on and go back to the
field subconscious is gone and when you
come back again guess what fresh
subconscious and you start all over
again so the subconscious is used now
for this life the conscious is always
here it's involved whether you're in
this body or not in this body and that
is the Perpetual person that you really
are the things that you wish for desire
want in your life and you have to work
hard sweat over it I'm putting a lot of
effort in I'm gonna make
welcome
why are you working so hard the answer
is beautiful because whatever that
destination is you don't have a program
to support it and you're trying to
override a habit that doesn't give you
what you want by putting more effort
into it and I go
good idea not good process why 95 of
your life is coming from a program uh
and five percent from this little
conscious mind up here cannot
mathematically if you think about the
subconscious of the million times more
powerful programmer than the conscious
mind I say and you want to write
override the subconscious I go boy
that's a that's not gonna work
very well uh and yet there are ways to
do it because if it didn't this is going
to be a lousy interview but there are
ways to rewrite it and the idea about it
is
if you understand the process
you can rewrite your life and change the
outcome you can change these programs
sometimes in 15 minutes or less okay but
you need to know how to do it okay uh
the relevance about all this is um uh uh
the movie The Matrix uh it's all of
Science Fiction I go no no no movie The
Matrix is a documentary what do you mean
I go premise everybody's been
programming go oh that's a given we are
all programmed from last trimester to
age seven everyone is but in the movie
they say well you can take a red pill
and get out of the program
and I want to suggest that most people
in our audience right now that we have
here today have taken the red pill at
one time or another and their life
profoundly changed okay when was that
one of the best examples is when people
fall in love I go what do you mean I go
well their life is blah blah blah blah
blah they fall in love they meet
somebody 24 hours later oh life is so
beautiful I'm so in love I'm so happy
look I'm glowing look I got growth
hormone in my system I go 24 hours later
after blah blah blah all those years and
24 hours later you manifest heaven on
Earth
how'd that happen and the answer is
beautiful because the answer is when you
fall in love you stop thinking you stay
present it's called staying mindful like
what does that mean I say when you're
thinking is when the subconscious
autopilot kicks in if you're not
thinking then the conscious creative
mind is the one that's manifesting your
life so I go the moment you fell in love
why would you think and the reason this
is you've been waiting for this person
your whole life they showed up you want
to think and disconnect from this I go
no you want to stay present you want to
be mindful you want to be there I go you
stop thinking I said what's the result
it's the red pill the moment you stop
thinking is you're not diverting to the
subconscious anymore you are operating
from conscious wishes and desires and so
the honeymoon is not an accident it's a
manifestation that says I'm not playing
the program we have a belief that only
physical matter is primary and we've
ignored the relevance of what's called
Energy and the new physics quantum
physics says you can't ignore the energy
the energy is what is actually shaping
the physical world so by leaving the
energy out of the equation we've missed
the the most important factor
spirituality mind is energy everything
we eat food is energy where we live is
energy so we have to talk about the
environment
of the invisible nature is what's
actually shaping our physical experience
on this planet it's a retake and it says
look stop focusing on this physical
plane start recognizing your thoughts
and your beliefs and spirituality and
energy around us are really reflected in
who we are there's a lot of people that
have doubts about the concept of the
influence of global meditation and
rightfully so because we've always been
programmed to ignore the invisible realm
as not being relevant to our world
but now with an understanding of quantum
physics and the role that the invisible
realm is more powerful in shaping the
Physical Realm then is the Physical
Realm itself it really adds emphasis to
the character that the energy fields in
which we live are actually shaping the
world that we experience
is this just a made-up idea that I just
said the answer is no there are
scientific studies that have shown how
meditation and groups have changed
characteristics of cities or towns in
regard to violence or love or what was
going on in the city so basically said
while meditators were in the practice of
their meditation and bringing peace to
the city it actually changed the people
in the city according to the statistics
Point did it work in answers absolutely
unfortunately when the meditators went
home the whole thing stopped point is
very simple
if we live with that spiritual activism
in our heart and use it every day then
this is not just an on and off event
this is a continuous process of shaping
the environment and the community in
which we live in the past if you looked
at it people have perceived themselves
as victims of everything around them
victims of circumstances and then we go
oh I'm I'm sorry life did not give me
those wonderful things that other people
have and the simple reality is no no if
you have an issue it's not the outside
this is what we've always old Universe
give me something we now know that our
issues are internal it's our own
subconscious beliefs that we've been
programmed with of disempowerment like
when a child is growing up and getting
its programs think of what things
parents say oh you don't deserve this
who do you think you are I mean the
parents didn't mean that for your whole
life they just they were trying to you
know goju you know needle you to make a
change so they would say these things
things
95 percent of our life comes from those
programs so if you have disempowering
beliefs about who you think you are
because you got them from other people
that's how you know who you are
these disempowering beliefs play 95 of
the day in an average person's life
so I say Yeah well my wishes and desires
I want success I want great
relationships I want all these wonderful
I want health I go well that's conscious
Minds because conscious mind's creative
but uh as science reveals only five
percent of the day are we operating from
our own personal wishes and desires 95
of the day we operate from the programs
that we got in the first seven years and
if those programs which psychologists
have told us 70 percent are negative and
disempowering and self-sabotaging they
say good apply these 95 a day in your
life and you realize why your life is a
struggle it's not a struggle because the
universe is not providing it's a
struggle because your own Consciousness
is not accepting
and this is where we have to change and
so getting control of your mind taking
charge of your Consciousness is a way of
overcoming those limitations there are
many different ways to to take this
control back in in your life and one of
them is the ability to uh like in yoga
for example to be the master of your
mind and not let it run the monkey mind
let it run no I want this I don't don't
let this other one go
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy so if you have all of your
attention in the present moment you're
conserving a lot of energy to create
with if I'm talking to you and you're
thinking about where you're gonna go for
lunch and who you're going to go with